after all the wild speculation and
conspiracy theories the coroner ruled
that Nicola Bully's death was an
accident
she tumbled into the river probably down
this steep bank and drowned it wasn't a
crime it wasn't suicide said the coroner
but exactly why she fell in is still a
mystery
Nicholas body was recovered from the
water at some Michael's on wire three
weeks later
after the verdict a solicitor spoke for
Nicholas family
whilst we'll never forget the volusoval
and Nikki we offer every member
brilliant mum
partner
daughter and sister that we all knew and
loved so very much it's upsetting that
we've continued to receive
negative targeted messages
and still wildly inaccurate speculation
being shared on numerous platforms
the coroner had been so worried about
disruption to the inquest that police
patrolled around the building he said
there have been threats of protests
inside and out
and conspiracy theories which have been
so damaging to Nikki's family and the
community it's a Michaels the inquest
heard that Nicola had struggled with the
effects of the menopause had alcohol
issues and suffered from anxiety
her sister Louise said she was so
worried she'd called a mental health
emergency team two weeks before Nicola
vanished it worked as a wake-up call
Nicola stopped drinking
Nicholas partner Paul Ansel told the
coroner she had recently turned her life
around
he said the blip over the Christmas
period happened but in January she was
back to herself looking forward to the
future and everything was on the up we
were good together I offered her
spontaneity and she was the planner she
was an incredible mum
the coroner was told that at the time
she vanished Nicola was excited by her
work prospects she was planning a spa
day and arranging a play date for her
daughter nobody who saw her that morning
thought there was anything wrong with
her
Nicholas family said they took comfort
in messages from strangers around the
world one day they said Nicholas two
daughters will read the many cards
filled with such kindness and love
Martin brunt Sky News Preston